I've always thought of you as a tough
guy you just said you're not afraid to
do any stunts but I did hear that you
are afraid of one thing there's one
thing that scares you yeah very
embarrassed
yeah it's you're embarrassing it's
you're you're scared of a needle
yeah I don't know why and so you can do
a stunt where you jump in front of a
train and get away at the last second
you yes no problem but or you could
might eat a needle yes
I just goose bump out I just I just I
just don't know why right yeah I I
remember I go to the hospital sometimes
I walk in everything Wow check it yeah
yeah later did you just hear the sound
and you're just getting a flu vaccine
after I get the doc by yeah I make a
movie to talk by me
yeah after bite I'm taking an injury
sure I go to the hospital then a room
that's a table with the wheel yes then I
take off my pen I did when when that the
the nurse coming again and do the COS
stock yeah but you are you running away
from the Nerds that is no I yeah I
understand it I understand it we all
have something
you